[Music]
jesus loves me this I know for the Bible
tells me so little one to him belong
they are weak but he is strong you were
called cotton I still believe that the
world needs to get saved
soldier my comfort my joy is known that
you're here to lead the way after the
black robber
Oh gone in the wrong direction
what does it matter already one thinks
matters to me people have been saying
that I stopped believing in hell and
heard a voice say everyone's already
saved I know you can't just rewrite the
by not rewriting anything I'm just
rereading it you speak the Word of God
in this church why don't you call me you
owe me that much
seriously son you need to consider
everything you're putting at risk and
not just for yourself you don't need to
be safe you don't know that I know that
you won't proof it wasn't a voice you
heard have for congregation walking out
that was it
either get with me or you're not Thunder
to install wall to wall but it's gonna
fit
[Music]
are you certain it was not as what you
heard
I've never been more sure of anything in
my life and I'm not backing down
[Music]